[Music]
2 am a few miles outside the city the
car tore down the asphalt at 60 miles an
hour we kept the beams low the dark road
around us only illuminated by the
occasional street lamp overhead things
moved unseen in the trees an old song
rattled off the radio the connection was
patchy so it was interrupted by
intermittent spikes of static it was the
kind of night when you knew deep down
that anything could happen you just
hoped that anything would be in your
favor i rolled the window down a few
minutes ago breathing in all that cold
fresh air to stave off the looming
specter of sleep thank god i wasn't the
one driving or things would have gotten
deadly way sooner cops would have found
us with our bumper wrapped around a tree
our heads one with the steering wheel or
the windshield dead on impact or from
the unforgiving cold overnight they
might have even felt sorry for us until
they found the case perhaps it would
have been better that way at least it
would have been quick a lot of bad
things can happen on lonely state
highways in the dead of night and we
were about to find out that just
crashing your car was one of the more
mild ones scott was driving he was also
the one who brokered this whole deal i
was just coming along to provide backup
there was a fully loaded saturday night
special sitting in my inner coat pocket
hoping that it wouldn't see any action
tonight and a pump action shotgun
sitting in the back in case things got
really hairy deals like this you either
come well prepared or reckoned with a
heavy chance you sure as hell won't be
leaving i never asked scott how he came
into the goods currently sitting in the
briefcase and he never offered an
explanation either he only told me that
he'd already secured a very interested
potential buyer from a syndicate out of
town serious people dangerous people
they'd pay top dollar or leave us tied
up in trash bags in a ditch off the side
of the highway but we both needed money
and we were willing to take that risk if
it meant we could return from the steel
as a pair of rich men the terms of the
deal were simple we drive out onto a
certain state highway add a little after
2 am with the goods meet the buyers at a
certain rest stop along the way and make
the exchange we then all go our separate
ways and if we were lucky none of us
would ever see each other ever again
seems simple enough sure scott seemed
downright chipper about the whole thing
and for a little while i was excited too
until he told me about the road that the
buyers wanted to meet us on we'd all
heard legends about the place
superstitions really people think
criminals are scary but believe me we're
a surprisingly superstitious bunch our
profession is one largely based on luck
being in the right place at the right
time and being lucky enough to avoid the
cops along the way but something you
need to know whether you're a criminal
or arrow straight is that some places
are always going to be the wrong place
i'm not going to tell you which road it
is i know what you knuckleheads are like
you're curious you're thrill seekers hey
we are all young ones but if i tell you
what this road is i know you're gonna
try to find it maybe you'll even decide
it's worth the trip down for a pleasant
sunday drive
after what i went through on that road i
wouldn't wish a trip down it on my worst
enemy there's no other word for what we
encountered there other than evil when
we were kids we used to call it the
devil's passage every spooky rumor and
scary story in the book circulated about
that place
let me see what i can remember well
there was the watcher in the woods
people used to say that there was a long
tall figure with the biggest eyes you
had ever seen eyes like headlights
standing amongst the trees if the
moonlight shone in the right angle as
you were driving past you'd see it
standing there just staring at you
thinking about doing who knows what then
there was old beth the ghostly
hitchhiker people used to say they saw a
strange old woman hobbling down the side
of the road in the middle of the night
sometimes people said that they could
hear her crying even if they were far
enough away to make such a thing seem
impossible if you took pity on her and
pulled over asking her if she needed a
ride she'd tell you that you were a very
kind person but that she was fine and
dandy walking along by herself but if
you didn't stop and offer her a lift if
you just drove away well local legend
had it that the next time you'd see her
face would be in your rear view mirror
as she sat in your back seat reaching
for you with her ancient bony claws it'd
make you think twice about leaving an
old woman to walk home alone in the dark
and of course there was the lone jogger
the stories my dad told me about him
always used to scare the hell out of me
he was a pale man dressed unnaturally
light for the cold winter months jogging
along the side of the road if you looked
at him he'd look back if your eyes ever
met the stories went that he'd start
running after you it wouldn't matter how
fast you drove he'd somehow always catch
up and stare at you through the glass of
your car's windows he never hurt anyone
directly but i imagine he probably
caused a heart attack or two in his time
if he ever really existed but all these
things were nothing i repeat
nothing compared to the phantom cruiser
you have to drive cautiously at night
because if you didn't you might find a
ghostly 1970s police cruiser tailgating
you and that'd be the worst thing you
ever saw there were fewer stories about
this one than all the others because if
you ever ran a foul of the phantom
cruiser chances are that you wouldn't
survive to tell people about what
happened to you though people could
still make an educated guess about what
happened to you based on whatever was
left behind here's a not so fun fact the
devil's passage is technically qualified
for one of the most dangerous highways
in the country from crashes to
hitchhiker murders to unexplained deaths
on the side of the road since 1974 this
road has been an incredibly unpleasant
place to drive every time i saw another
horror story about a strange death on
the road i'd think of the phantom
cruiser and it was those same thoughts
polluting my brain that night as scott
drove the two of us to the rest stop
halfway down the devil's passage i only
realized i dozed off when he nudged me
awake and the blurry lights of distant
street lamps flashed into my field of
vision look alive he said we're here the
rest stop wasn't much to look at all
that there was was an abandoned gas
station really the perfect place for
this kind of illicit deal my hand moved
instinctively to the special in my coat
and clicked back the hammer something
about this whole setup wasn't right
sting operation police ambush this whole
thing reeked of a deal too good to be
true my instincts turned out to be right
in the sense just not the way i was
expecting as we turned into the rest
stop scott turned up his beams all we
saw was carnage waiting for us a car
presumably one that once belonged to our
prospective buyers in a state of
horrific disarray it looked as though a
train had impacted the side of the
vehicle completely caving it in the
metal was covered in deep scratches and
ruts that almost looked like claw marks
it had been eviscerated scott broke hard
we both got out of the car i drew the
special out of my jacket and he grabbed
the shotgun out of the back seat we
approached with caution worrying this
might just be another part of the setup
until we saw the thick puddle of blood
congealing under the driver's side door
we drew closer propelled by morbid
curiosity was it a hit from a rival gang
looking to intercept the deal seemed
logical but there were no bullet holes
in the car just ripping tearing and
massive impact damage scott shined the
light of his phone into the destroyed
car and i vomited when i saw what was
inside the buyers looked less like
people and more like two sacks of pulled
pork and tattered clothes if i hadn't
seen them inside the car i wouldn't have
even guessed they were human and the
damage wasn't just to them the
upholstery was torn up and burned with
violent symbols carved into the walls
and scrawled onto the cracked windows
and blood when i turned to scott he was
ghost white clutching his phone and
shotgun with trembling hands we didn't
exchange a word but we both knew it was
time to leave we could find another
buyer there'd be other opportunities
other deals but lives you only get one
and we both silently acknowledge that if
we stuck around here much longer we
wouldn't even have that we sped back
into the car and locked the doors behind
us for whatever good that would do
considering the damage that had been
done to the buyers in their car perhaps
we just needed the illusion of security
to get us the hell out of there the car
pulled out of the rest stop at breakneck
speed scott flirted trying to put some
good distance between us and the horror
at that rest stop whatever had happened
to the buyers we didn't fancy sharing
that same awful fate my heart dropped
down to my guts when i heard the sirens
and flashing lights behind us after all
this we'd been busted for speeding
they'd pull us over and find the guns in
the briefcase in the car and they'd have
a lot of questions that neither of us
would have good answers to we didn't
know whether to slow down and hope for
the best or speed up and take this boy
in blue on a genuine car chase this
whole thing couldn't have gone more
wrong but my thoughts soon drifted from
getting used to the taste of prison food
to something altogether more sinister
when i saw the car getting closer in the
rearview mirror i realized that this
wasn't a modern cop car tailing us it
was a beat up old 70s cruiser traveling
at insane speeds gaining on us the high
beams cut through me like razor blades i
heard the radio crackle into life even
though neither i nor scott touched it it
wasn't music just a hoarse scratchy
voice repeating the word run
again and again and seeing as whatever
was behind us clearly wasn't a real cop
we were more than happy to oblige that
request scott hit the gas like our lives
depended on it which to be fair they did
but no matter how fast we sped up the
cruiser kept getting closer like a demon
on our tail i screamed at scott to go
faster but we were going as fast as we
could next thing i knew the phantom
cruiser collided with the backside of
our car and sent us into a spin
showering the two of us with broken
glass crystals as the tires screeched
across the asphalt felt like an eternity
before the car came to a rest and at
that moment the phantom cruiser stopped
too someone got out he was dressed like
a cop he even looked like a cop a dude
in his 40s balding overweight with a
handlebar mustache but something was
wrong about him he didn't say a word as
he approached the car and he didn't seem
to register me sliding the special out
of my jacket either he was inches away
from scott's window when i panicked and
opened fire sending a hail of small
caliber rounds into his gut he stumbled
back slightly as though shocked and then
everything got a whole lot worse the cop
let out the most awful bellow not of
pain but of pure rage something happened
to his face his eyes started to glow a
bright hellish red and his jaw began to
extend until he looked like a munch
painting there were no teeth in there
just an infinite black void he grabbed a
day scott through the window pulling him
into a brutal headlock and dragging him
out of the car releasing those deranged
bellows the entire time scott screamed
and pleaded for help i grabbed his body
and tried to pull him back but the cop
was inhumanly strong he just kept
pulling until he was all the way out
thrashing on the asphalt i i don't want
to tell you what he did next wouldn't be
right but suffice to say i couldn't save
scott and i definitely didn't want it
happening to me while he was working on
scott i scrambled into the driver's seat
and floored it hoping that scott would
at least buy me some time i was weeping
in terror as i drove away into the dark
leaving my friend to a horrible fate
with the driver of the phantom cruiser
so you can only imagine how i felt when
a few minutes later i heard the sirens
again and saw the bright lights getting
closer behind me run
run
run
now go check out
scp-002 the living room and the most
terrifying scp rooms and the secret at
the bottom of
scp-087 explain for more scp videos
that'll give you nightmares